This episode of Dnews was proudly made possible
by the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
It’s not just a sedan, it’s a Subaru.
A new study finds that women are better drivers
than men!
Finally, science gives us a win!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and we’ve
all heard the old adage that women are terrible
drivers.
The problem with that, though - aside from
being horribly sexist - is that it’s just
not true.
According to a 2012 study, men are responsible
for more traffic violations than women, in
almost every single category - from reckless
driving, to failure to yield, to speeding.
Even scarier, is the fact that 80% of all
fatal and serious car crashes are caused by
men.
And when it comes to DUI violations, male
drivers outnumber females 3 to 1.
As far as statistics go, those are pretty
damning - but a new study out of Kansas State
University, breaks it down even further - showing
exactly what kinds of crashes are more likely
to be caused by which gender.
Researchers looked at data from every motor
vehicle crash in Kansas from 2007-2011, to
see if there were any gender discrepancies
amongst drivers age 16-24.
Past studies have repeatedly shown that age
is the single more important factor in highway
safety.
Young drivers and old drivers, are involved
in more car crashes than any other age group.
But there are some new statistics in this
study, that shed light on the specific behaviors
of men and women.
Young females, for example, are 66% more likely
to wear a seatbelt than young males, and 28%
more likely to drive on a restricted license.
Women are also involved in more pedestrian
collisions and crashes at intersections, while
men are more likely to be involved in off-road
crashes.
Interestingly, time of day also seems to makes
a big difference.
Young men, for example, seem to be worse night
drivers - as they’re significantly more
likely to be involved in an accident after
sunset.
They also get into more crashes on the weekend
- while young women, are the opposite - they’re
more likely to have an accident on the weekdays.
It’s not totally clear what the reason is
behind these differences - but a lot of the
statistics in this study appear to be interconnected.
For example, the fact that men are involved
in more off-road crashes, could be linked
to the fact that they’re more likely to
speed on rural roads.
Of course, men and women DO have different
behaviors and attitudes when it comes to driving,
but those differences seem to be especially
pronounced, the younger you are.
Let’s face it - if there’s one thing teenagers
are good at, it’s making poor decisions.
While we’re on the topic of driving, we
wanna extend a quick thank you to Subaru,
for making this episode possible.
And especially the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy
- it offers a safer and more dynamic ride
than ever before, and it goes where other
sedans simply can’t.
In the meantime, let us know in the comments
below what you think of this study - and if
you agree with the notion that women are better
drivers than men.
That’s all for me, but as always - thank
you guys for watching!